بينما يثير صمود الاقتصاد الروسي الاعجاب
خسر الاعلام معركته قبل ان تبدا الاعلام
الرسمي الذي كبلته الروايه الرسميه وحررت
عناوينه بيانات وزاره الدفاع غرق بين
تقارير الحرب التي يتلوها
في الصباح والبث المباشر اليومي لبرنامج
كل سهره لم يدم الامر طويلا حتى شك الروس
في ان الامور تسير حسب الخطه وهنا دفعهم
تحري الحقيقه الى المنصه الوحيده الناجيه
من رقبه الكرملين وحظر الغرب منصه
تيليجرام حولت صحفيين مغمورين الى نجوم
حرب اتفاقهم على دعم الكريم لم يمنعه من
تعريه الواقع وهنا خرجت الامور عن السيطره
الثاني من ابريل الماضي مقهى مملوك
لبريجوجن ينفجر مخلفا قتلى وجرحى ابرزهم
فاديم احد اشهر المراسلين الحربيين اذفاق
متابعه على تيليجرام 600 الف
اقترب من فاجنر اكثر من وزاره الدفاع حتى
انه انتقد علانيه رافت الجيش بالاوكرانيين
وفاته لا تزال لغزا لكن اتهاما مزدوجا
ووجه لكيف وانصار نافالي وبحجه استهداف
الكتاب والصحفيين طلب من المدونين تقليل
نشاطهم امر تناقض مع ارسال روسيا الاف
المواطنين من ابنائها نحو الجبهه
اسم اخر الكسندر سلادكوف مراسل عسكري غطى
كل حروب الاتحاد الروسي تخطى متابعه على
تيليجرام المليون وهو ضعف المشتركين في
قناه وزاره الدفاع
ينقل مشاهد حيه من الميدان ولا يتردد في
ذكر الحقائق وانتقاد الجميع حتى ان البعض
من مواده تتبناها وسائل الاعلام الغربيه
مشهد فريد فرضته الحرب في روسيا اعلام
متحررون ينتقد الجميع تقريبا وقد لا تمنعه
الا خطوه او هزيمه واحده حتى يصبح بوتين
نفسه في مرمى الانتقادات في قنوات يتابعها
الملايين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات